Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Vous avez fait quoi de beau pendant
votre confinement de 2020, vous ?
Moi, je suis devenu collapso.
C'est un terme assez récent qui
caractérise la conviction que globalement,
l'humanité va dans le mur.
Avant, je bossais dans la tech,
ou la «start-up nation»,
comme on dit en français.
Et mon job, c’était l’hyper-croissance,
c’est-à-dire cravacher pour que
sa start-up devienne une licorne,
une entreprise qui vaut
plus d’un milliard de dollars.
Et à l’époque, ma vision du monde,
mon rêve, bah ça ressemblait à ça.
Puis arrive le confinement en 2020,
entre Zoom caméra coupée,
chômage partiel et fin du monde,
je me suis retrouvé avec du temps
pour me demander s’il était vraiment
compatible avec le futur, ce rêve.
Et j’ai donc fait ce que font toutes les
âmes en perdition et en quête de sens :
j’ai ouvert YouTube.
(Rires)
Et premier arrêt, Jean-Marc Jancovici
qui m’a aidé à comprendre
le problème du climat.
Mais en enchaînant, je me suis assez vite
rendu compte qu’il y avait aussi
la biodiversité qui s’effondre,
les pollutions qui sont partout,
dans les sols, dans l’eau, dans l’air,
les ressources naturelles qui s’épuisent.
Tous ces problèmes-là
sont connectés, en fait.
Et là, ma vision du monde, mon rêve,
sont devenus un peu moins paillettes.
(Rires)
J’ai changé des choses depuis, c’est sûr.
Je mange beaucoup moins de viande,
j’ai remplacé mon gel douche par un savon.
Je porte deux pulls en hiver
au lieu d’augmenter le chauffage
et j’offre même des bouquins écolo
à mes parents à tous les Noëls.
Sauf que
tous les papiers scientifiques un minimum
sérieux sont parfaitement clairs.
Ça ne suffit pas et ça ne suffit
même pas du tout.
Et arrivé là, je n’ai qu’un mot
qui me vient à la bouche :
« Merde. »
Qu’est-ce que vous voulez
que je fasse de plus, moi ?
Il y en a sûrement là-haut ou là-bas qui
pourraient en faire un peu plus, non ?
On est des millions à penser
la même chose.
Et j'ai un pote qui décrit ça
de façon simple et élégante
avec le triangle de l'inaction.
État, citoyens, entreprises ;
chacun a une bonne raison de trouver
que c’est à l’autre de bouger.
L’État dit qu’il fait ce
pour quoi il a été élu.
Le citoyen dit qu'il achète ce qu'on
lui offre et fait ce qu'on lui dit.
Et l’entreprise dit qu’elle produit
ce qu’on lui demande
et joue dans les règles du jeu.
Mais il n'y a pas 36 solutions
pour sortir de ce triangle.
Quelqu'un doit faire le premier pas.
Il faut que quelqu'un trouve
le courage de le faire.
Et il faut que ce quelqu’un ait
suffisamment de pouvoir
pour que ça fasse la différence.
Si on commence par la société civile,
il y a une réserve de courage
absolument incroyable là-dedans.
Scientifiques, activistes, artistes,
speakers TEDx,
on en a tous au moins un ou une
qui nous inspire.
Mais est-ce qu’ils ont du pouvoir ?
C’est souvent symbolique
et c’est souvent compliqué.
Côté politiques,
du pouvoir,
il y en a, c’est la Constitution
qui le dit.
Mais c’est côté courage
que ça se complique assez vite.
Parce que la politique est
un métier de consensus
où oser la radicalité, c’est risquer
de sauter à la prochaine élection
ou au prochain remaniement ministériel.
Et donc, le politique
ne fait pas le premier pas.
Il accompagne des tendances
avec des règles et des incitations.
Restent alors les entreprises.
Est-ce qu’elles ont du pouvoir ?
Ah, oui !
Est-ce que ces gens-là ont du courage ?
Vous avez peut-être d’autres mots
à l’esprit en voyant leur tête.
Mais moi, j’ai la conviction
qu’on trouve dans l’entreprise
un potentiel de courage
absolument incroyable
et que ça commence tout en haut,
par la dirigeante et le dirigeant.
C’est une conviction qui me vient
d’un projet que j’entreprends
avec d’autres depuis
un peu plus de deux ans.
La Convention des Entreprises
pour le Climat, la CEC.
On est en septembre 2020.
J'écris une série d'articles sur
l'hypothèse d'un marketing écolo.
Je poste ça sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tombe dessus un mec
avec une idée un peu barrée.
Et si on s’inspirait de la Convention
Citoyenne pour le Climat
pour faire bosser 150 patrons
pendant un an
sur la transformation écologique
de leur boîte ?
Là, vous avez une bonne
partie de ce collectif,
à la sixième et dernière session
du parcours qu’on a imaginé.
150 entreprises.
150 binômes de dirigeants par entreprise.
Et ça m’a scotché de voir
et de vivre avec eux pendant un an,
leur transformation.
Il y a eu un souffle, il y a eu un
retroussement de manches général
et c’est pendant cette aventure
que la notion de courage a vraiment
commencé à me travailler.
Et ma conviction,
c’est qu’il ne suffit pas
d’un potentiel de courage,
ça se travaille !
Et je vois trois ingrédients pour ça :
le cœur, le collectif
et le récit.
Premier ingrédient : le cœur.
Et on commence plutôt avec du lourd :
vous avez déjà demandé à
votre patron d’écouter son cœur ?
Non, ce qu'il veut ou ce qu'elle veut,
ce sont des chiffres.
Les chiffres, c'est précis, ça rassure
et ça rentre dans une feuille Excel.
Mais c’est aussi froid, c’est distant
et c’est le meilleur outil
pour s’auto-convaincre
que tout problème écologique
à une solution technologique.
Genre des canons à neige
qui réchauffent la planète
pour remplacer la neige qui fond
parce que la planète se réchauffe.
Toucher le cœur, ça veut dire
comprendre les chiffres
et laisser leurs conséquences
descendre dans les tripes.
Se laisser ressentir ce que veut
dire un climat +3°C,
une biodiversité effondrée,
ou des sols sur lesquels on ne peut
plus rien faire pousser.
Pour beaucoup de participants,
c’est passé par une question :
quel est le monde
que je vais léguer à mes enfants ?
On avait même un exercice dédié
pour ça : la lettre à un enfant du futur.
Écrire,
après deux jours de conférences
scientifiques et de débats,
ce qu’on a compris de l’état
du monde, ce qu’on ressent,
et ce qu’on va y faire.
Le tout dans une lettre vouée
à être lue en 2040.
Raphaël, le PDG France
d’une boîte américaine
qui produit des engins de chantier jaunes,
a ouvert la sienne avec cette phrase :
«Lucie, ma chérie, je pars en croisade.»
Et Lucie, 23 ans,
je l’ai fait monter sur scène à la
cérémonie de clôture de la CEC
pour boucler la boucle
et qu’elle réponde à son père,
devant lui et les 300 autres dirigeants.
Elle a commencé en disant :
«On ne va quand même pas me faire croire
qu’après 30 ans à produire des engins
qui déforestent l’Amazonie,
il suffit de trois ateliers les pieds
dans l’herbe pour changer le monde.»
Ça a fait marrer les dirigeants
et les journalistes dans la salle.
Mais surtout,
elle a continué en partageant
que de voir son père s’engager
aux côtés de 300 de ses confrères
pour prendre des risques ensemble
et prouver que l’entreprise
peut faire beaucoup plus,
ça l’avait touché, ça l’avait émue et ça
l’avait inspirée à elle-même s’engager.
Ce qui nous amène
à notre deuxième ingrédient :
après le cœur, le collectif.
Parce qu’on ne va pas se mentir,
un dirigeant, une dirigeante,
ça vit le plus souvent son contraire :
la solitude à jongler entre
collaborateurs, comité de direction,
actionnaires, clients, fournisseurs,
les syndicats, le régulateur, les médias,
avec l’impératif culturel, plutôt
masculin, de ne pas montrer de faiblesse.
Et dans ce cas-là, pour s’en défendre,
la dirigeante, le dirigeant se met
le plus souvent à porter un masque
pour s’en défendre.
Et quand en plus, on vient l’emmerder
avec une transformation écologique
qui rend tout plus cher et plantera sa
boîte si les concurrents ne suivent pas,
le masque, il se transforme en armure.
Sauf que, quand on est dirigeant,
qu’on a pris le temps de comprendre
et qu’en ressort l’humilité
de se laisser toucher au cœur,
on ne peut pas rester coincé
dans son armure.
On comprend que sauver notre
civilisation sera un effort collectif
et on se met à aller vers l’autre,
à chercher la coopération.
Un de mes exemples préférés pour ça,
c’est celui de Sophie,
la directrice générale d’une marque
de dermo-cosmétiques pour enfants.
En gros, elle vend
des crèmes en pharmacie,
qui est le royaume des emballages
plastiques individuels
et des soins pas tous très naturels.
J’espère qu’il n’y a pas
de pharmaciens dans la salle.
L’armure n’était déjà pas bien épaisse,
donc la mise en action
est venue assez vite.
Un des objectifs
qu’elle s’est donnés pour 2035,
c’est que ces crèmes deviennent 100%
solides et soient vendues 100% en vrac.
Et pour valider l’idée,
elle a testé un joli concept
de bornes dédiées en pharmacie.
Le problème c’est que
personne ne les remarquait.
Elles étaient petites, elles étaient
dans un coin et ça n’a pas marché.
Mais la décision qu’elle a prise alors,
ça a été de décrocher son téléphone,
d'appeler ses concurrents pour former
une coalition du vrac en pharmacie.
Parce que si une borne,
ça ne se remarque pas,
un mur entier de vrac : si.
Et moi, je trouve cet exemple
hyper-puissant
parce que ça raconte un bout
de futur très différent.
Dans un monde où on n’achèterait
plus que du vrac en pharmacie,
imaginez un peu tout ce qui pourrait
avoir changé d’autre
autour de ce petit commerce-là.
Ce qui nous amène
à notre troisième ingrédient :
après le cœur et le collectif,
le récit.
Parce que,
c’est quoi le récit dominant de la
transition écologique aujourd’hui ?
Les Amishs contre
les techno-solutionnistes,
les éco-anxieux contre
les climato-sceptiques.
Greta Thunberg contre Pascal Praud.
(Rires)
Franchement,
ça vous donne envie
d’être écolo ça, vous ?
Non. Et je vous comprends.
On trouve l’énergie et l’envie
de transformer la société
et de se transformer soi,
quand on se laisse habiter par un récit
qui est désirable et puissant.
Martin Luther King et
«I have a dream», par exemple,
c’est désirable quand on n’est
pas raciste et c’est puissant.
Avec une bonne dose de lâcher-prise,
on se met assez vite à se projeter
dans ce genre de récit.
Et j’en veux pour preuve Marie,
la directrice générale
d’un des quatre opérateurs
de bateaux-mouches sur la Seine.
Elle était assise à ma droite,
le 19 janvier 2022,
pendant une audition de la CEC
par l’Assemblée nationale.
35 députés face à nous et Marie,
qui décrit son business en disant :
«Mon métier consiste à faire
faire des ronds dans l’eau
à des touristes chinois, qui sont à Paris
pour 36 h avec un Easyjet payé 50 euros,
qui sur mes bateaux vont acheter
des tours Eiffel en plastique
produites chez eux.»
(Rires)
Ma Marie,
elle en est sortie en larmes
de la première session de la CEC
consacrée au constat
de l’état de la planète.
Fin de journée, 23h30,
elle me regarde et elle me dit :
«J’ai trois enfants.
Ce n’est pas possible. »
Elle a vécu cet électrochoc
comme une invitation à ouvrir grand
le champ des possibles.
Rien qu’une session plus tard,
elle se posait des questions comme :
« Et si mes bateaux transportaient
autre chose que des touristes ? »
« Et si mes bateaux dépolluaient
la Seine plutôt que de la polluer ? »
« Et si je revégétalisais
mon bout de quai ? »
« Et si je participais à la régénération
des populations de poissons du fleuve ? »
Elle m’avait invité
à un lâcher de brochet.
Ben,
imaginez un peu à quoi
ressemblerait la Seine à Paris,
rien que si les quatre opérateurs de
bateaux-mouches exploraient ces récits-là,
ces questions-là,
tous ensemble, en collectif,
en se laissant porter par leur cœur.
Cœur, collectif et récit,
ces trois ingrédients qui malheureusement,
trouvent difficilement leur place
dans un modèle de société
individualiste et consumériste.
Mais je ne pense pas inventer l’eau chaude
en disant que ces trois
choses-là font de nous
des humains.
Et en deux ans de rencontres avec
des patrons, des députés, des ministres,
des gens qu’on peut considérer
avoir du pouvoir,
je me suis fait un avis assez tranché.
C'est tous des humains.
Ils ont eux aussi, elles aussi,
leurs doutes,
leurs dissonances et leur armure.
Moi, ça, ça me donne du courage.
Il n’y a pas de fatalité.
Pas encore et pas maintenant.
Et moi, j'ai un rêve pour 2030.
Je crois au fond de mes tripes
qu’on peut rendre irrésistible une
nouvelle norme culturelle de leadership,
de leaders qui ont le courage
d’être humain,
de dire : «Je ne sais pas tout,
je ne contrôle pas tout.
Moi aussi, j’ai peur.
Mais on va y aller
et on va y aller ensemble.»
Et la CEC, c’est juste une façon
parmi des centaines d’autres
de la faire basculer, cette norme.
Mais si je vous ai transmis
avec mon histoire
un début de soupçon d’étincelle,
alors j’ai envie de croire que mon rêve
pour 2030 n’est pas déconnant.
(Applaudissements)